le tristement célèbre Hank Palmer, l'
avocat blasé sans respect pour la loi qui
vient d'arriver, qu'est-ce que ça fait de savoir que
chaque personne que vous représentez est coupable,
c'est bien,
des gens innocents ne peuvent pas se permettre de me payer,
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose que l'un ou l'autre avocat
enfant ajoute que ma mère est décédée ce  le matin
est-ce la première fois que je suis
décédé ou y a-t-il quelque chose que vous faites sur tous
les cas que vous êtes sur le point de perdre la première
fois alors grand-père Palmer est mort aussi
pas grand-père Palmer est mort pour moi c'est comme
une figure de style semble compliqué  Je
devrais y aller avec toi crois moi personne ne
veut aller à Carlinville Indiana construire ces
murs une histoire les gars vous allez vous effondrer
vous pouvez à peine vous voir les
uns les autres
Henry Judge Hank merci d'être
venu  hé Hank Palmer Hank
shérif blanc c'est concernant la
plus grosse erreur de ton père dans ta carrière et tu l'as
juste écrasé la
médecine légale a trouvé des traces de sang sur
la voiture de ton père que j'ai versé sur le banc de ce
tribunal  oom pendant 42 ans c'était une
période accidentelle nous devons établir une
défense ferme il n'y a pas de nous ici Henry
j'aimerais t'aimer plus
je ne peux pas rester d'où il est ton
père tu pars maintenant tu attrapes ton
nickel en bois brillant mr  .  Palmer je
vais empaler ton client sur l'
accusation de meurtre au premier degré et tu as une place au
premier rang
mon père il y a beaucoup de
choses désagréables ou de meurtriers pas de femmes j'ai des
souvenirs de nous alors ce n'est pas le mien j'étais
dur avec toi  oui j'ai fait ce que je pensais
être juste mon expérience Hank parfois
tu dois pardonner pour être
pardonné
ohayo finalement fait ou nous n'avons pas fini
toi